[Musica]
Buonasera Grazie per l'invito e prenderò
pochi minuti mi hanno detto che c'era un
tempo previsto di circa 12 minuti avevo
previsti circa 40 perché loog stare in e
i tempi più europei il coraggio delle
idee e l'idea di partenza di questo
evento nel mio caso il coraggio diid è
quello di dedicare che a parte della mia
attività giornalistica Io sono già stato
presentato lavoro in un programma che si
chiama neene che è uno dei programmi più
longevi della kingu italiana e che
potete immaginarlo come un grande
ristorante internazionale dove la cucina
è molto varia la cucina è molto grande
Ci sono tanti tanti atetti a queste
cucine con le loro specialità e e questo
ne ha garantito nel tempo
la
sopravvivenza io sono arrivato in questo
programma da pochi anni mi considero un
neo arrivato che ho concentrato gran
parte della mia
attività a delle storie che poi nella
sostanza sono delle storie di cronaca
nera ma nel mio caso personalissimo io
non ho nessuna passione per la cronaca
nera ho scoperto e sono testimone dei
grandi libi che i tracp dei fatti di
cronaca nera Hanno dell'impatto
poemo dire nefasto che ha su' opinione
pubblica e della necessità che si cambi
un po' la narrazione questo perché lo
dico lo dico perché la cronaca nera in
Italia racconta molto poco del fatto che
è accaduto che si vorrebbe raccontare ma
racconta molto delle qualità morali del
pubblico quando capita un crimine eato
sul quale non ci sono
perché la prova diciamo si è rapidamente
raggiunta e voi scoprirete di vivere un
paese dove siete circondati da persone
che vorrebbero la pena di morte e che
vorrebbero domare la legge del taglione
Occhio per occhio dente perdente
invece per fortuna viviamo in una
società che queste idee le ha rilegate
un andolino buio che può farsi vanto di
garantire un c processo di riconoscere i
diritti imputati anche degli imputati
Dei crimini più
estati non sono appassionato di storie
di con canera Ma sono appassionato di
quelle storie che ci consentono di
apprezzare quanto spesso e quanto facile
il meccanismo giudiziario possa
commettere degli errori G possa
commettere nelle parte delle indagini G
possa commettere nella parte della
decisione
e per fare per capire quanto è
importante difendere questa idea è il il
ruolo del giornalismo Che cos'è il
giornalismo il
giornalismo cosiddetto è è un è una
forma di potere è una forma di potere
diffuso è una forma di potere che viene
esercitato dal pubblico attraverso
quelle persone che si incaricano di
mettersi in mezzo media tra i fatti che
succedono e le persone che tipo i fatti
vogliono avere delle informazioni essere
informati bene e per esercitare questo
ruolo bisogna per banalizzare og volta
essere dei
termometri
se voi utilizzate il termometro perché
sentite di stare male corso e avete la
febbre credo che nessuno vi abbia mai
consigliato di rompere il termometro per
guarire da R
fendre questo un
po' serve a non montarmi la testa Io
sono un termometro e posso dirvi che
avete la febbre poi gli an c cura
aspetta ad altri poteri altri poteri che
sono sempre dei poteri delicati perché
alla fine ciascuno dei poteri che
governano vità di una democrazia vengono
eh vengono dalla dall'insieme della sua
della popolazione di uno stato bene eh
questa forma di potere che il
giornalismo è una forma di controllo
l'esercizio di quel potere e negli
ultimi 30 anni nelle democrazie nelle
democrazie occidentali e la forma di
controllo dei principali in due poteri
quello legislativo e quello esecutivo ha
raggiunto dei livelli che potremmo
definire accettani notevoli plaud Bili
non perdoniamo ni che amministra la cosa
pubblica non perdoniamo niente alla
pubblica amministrazione che sbaglia che
in efficente che spreca le risorse e ma
il ruolo del giornalismo in quanto
controllore di un altro potere quando
quel potere è quello giudiziario spesso
sonnia se il giornalismo non svolge con
lo stesso spirito cripo il taglio
dell'esercizio del potere giudiziario la
democrazia è meno mata ed è nomata in
uno dei suoi aspetti fondamentali che è
l'amministrazione della Giustizia e Che
cosa significa questo nel mio mestiere
significa esercitare due muscoli e in
questo lavoro in un programma che che è
una vera palestra Per esercitare questi
due muscoli il primo muscolo è la
curiosità è un muscolo che va sempre
esercitato no curiosità no giornalismo
questo magari ci P uno in sala che
potrebbe voler fare questo da grande il
secondo scolo è lo
stupore curiosità e stupore e io sono
molto legato sono nato a Reggio Calabria
sonma molto legato a questa regione e
qui a Mingo valenia ho avuto un esempio
di che cosa vuol dire giornalismo
giornalismo investigativo mi riferisco
al professor Giuseppe Brago che per
tanti anni si è stupato di una vicenda
che sta a cuore a agli abitanti della
mia città che Reg gabbia che i Bronzi di
Riace in cosa è consistito il suo lavoro
è non farsi andare bene la perse
ufficiale andare a cercare i documenti
ufficiali del ritrovamento dei Bronzi di
Race e scoprire che le cose non stavano
esattamente come erano state raccontate
nella mia personalissima esperienza mi
sono confrontato con qualcosa di più
scivoloso più pericoloso più rischioso
mettere in discussione ciò che è stato
accertato dall'autorità Venzi aria e
mettere in discusione quella che è la
sentenza definitiva che in Italia
probabilmente per un'eredità che viene
dalla nostra cultura cattolica Io sono
cattolico e mi sono stato in chieta e
prento la chiesa ma non ho difficoltà a
riconoscere alcuni aspetti deteriori di
questa cultura uno di questi è
considerare la sentenza che condanna Il
Vangelo secondo Matteo Il Evangelo della
rivelazione e considerare le sentenze di
assoluzione come la testimonianza di
qualcuno che l'ha patta Franca perché la
com bravo avocato
e l'idea coraggiosa è stata quella di
provare a sovvertire questo paradigma
dovete sapere che i giornali prendono
molto Cop molte copie e i programmi
televisivi fanno grandi ascolti sul
marketing che il marketing della
colpevolezza tizio è colpevole perché
l'hanno detto i carabinieri e i
carabinieri l'hanno detto perché
certamente sarà colpevole tizio è
colpevole perché lo ha stabilito una
sentenza definitiva e i giudici perché
dovrebbero scrivere qualcosa che è è il
contrario della realtà bene dovete
sapere che questa cosa capita con una
frequenza talmente alta che la media
delle revisioni dei processi penali in
Italia secondo l'armari statistico della
Cassazione Sono all'incirca 25
l'anno 25 l'anno una percentuale rision
all
0,03 della
produzione giudiziaria del sistema
penale italiano ma dietro quella
percentuale irrisoria ci sono le vite
delle persone vite di persone che sono
state private della cosa più importante
che è la rà in nome della legge su
delega del popolo italiano perché le
sentenze vengono pronunciate nel nel
nostro nome e abbiamo
questa questa narrazione e trato a fare
una cosa che mi ha molto affascinato i
denti dell'università io ho studiato
giurisprudenza Mi sono laureato con
molta calma perché ci ho messo più o
meno 18 anni da quando mi sono iscritto
a quando ho conseguito il titolo di
splio Nel mezzo ci ho messo un po' di
cose fatte in televisione questo lo dico
perché non scoraggiatevi non c'è non c'è
una data di scadenza del computer del
proprio percorso di studi e c'è però una
data di scadenza decidere che cosa si
vuole si voglia fare della propria vita
quello sì quindi decidetelo in fretta
poi il come e il quando soprattutto
arriverà e torno sul tema e cerco di
concludere nel modo più rapido possibile
che dicevo la crona Canela racconta poco
del fatto racconta molto del pubblico Il
secondo aspetto è che si dice Ma come fa
a esserci una frequenza così alta D
terrore giudiziario vero prent Io adesso
qui difendo il diritto il coraggio di
un'idea il diritto di poter dubitare
anche della pronuncia giudiziaria perché
siamo un po' precipitati con malinteso
veniamo da 3 anni per Stan stati
contrassegnati dalla pandemia nel quale
il dibattito ha come dire si è
inevitabilmente spostato su un tema
scientifico e quando si tratta di dire
che 2 per 2 fa 4 non c'è equilibrio non
c'è pluralità di voci 2x 2 fa 4 e chi
dice che 2 per 2 fa 5 non ha diritto di
tribuna non ha non c'è diritto a poter
dire che la
non è rotonda ok E però quando poi
investiamo il campo delle scienze
sociali che sono scienze imperfette per
natura l'altro stick in mano agli uomini
esserei imperfetti per definizione può
Certamente contenere in te degli sbagli
e Come ci si accorge della
possibilità che una sentenza custodisca
un errore giudiziari o se non si è
arrivati a una sentenza che le indagini
preliminari in caso non hanno fatto non
hanno esplorato tutte le strade
percorribili tutte le strade esplorabili
Beh lo si fa facendo qualcosa di
estremamente faticoso
e sfogliare centinaia se non migliaia se
non decine di migliaia di pagine e
confrontare quello che è contenuto
all'interno di quelle pagine con la
realtà dei fatti con la realtà oggettiva
dei fatti e tutte le volte in cui sorge
un contrasto Sarà lecito e coltivare un
dubbio si dice ma le decisioni avvengono
della massima trasparenza la sentenza è
pubblica gli atti diventano pubblici e i
giornalisti li possono pubblicare
pensate però che già nel 1989 un maestro
del diritto che si chiama Claudio
giostra aveva un timore che approvava a
spiegare con queste parole È vero che la
sentenza la publicazione della sentenza
rende in qualche modo il processo
giudiziario trasparente ma siamo sicuri
che questa forma di controllo venga
effettivamente esercitata dai cittadini
su come viene amministrata la giustizia
e non sia invece una forma di controllo
da parte di chi esercita la giustizia
sulla direzione che prende l'opinione
pubblica Provate a tare a questa cosa
magari lo dette in modo complicato ma se
i giornali scrivono che l'intuizione del
pubblico ministero è vera perché è
supportata da quello che hanno scoperto
i Carabinieri e che quello per che hanno
scoperto i carabinieri è portato dalla
legittimazione che gli viene data dal
pubblico ministero che quelle indagini
ha delegato capite che questo diventa un
circuito che si autoalimenta e che
autole legittima se
stesso dovete sapere che questa cosa in
Italia è molto obbligata da realizzare
Cosa mettere in discussione il risultato
della sentenza perché in Italia la
giurisprudenza ha stabilito che se sei
un giornalista e se riporti tra
virgolette quello che è scritto nella
richiesta del Pubblico Ministero
nell'ordinanza del Giudice delle
indagini preliminari nella sentenza sei
al riparo da qualunque azione
giudiziaria e questo Devo dire che il
muscolo della curiosità il muscolo dello
stupore li ha un po' impigriti li
impigrisce li atrofizza e e invece il
potere va sempre come dire osservato con
cautela osservato con diffidenza non
esiste un giornalista non esiste un
giornalista affidabile che non abbia che
non coltivi un briciolo di sa diffidenza
nei confronti del potere qualunque esso
sia e da chiunque venga esercitato
compresa la diffidenza del pubblico nei
confronti dei giornalisti che esercitano
il loro potere di controllo il loro
potere di controllo dico questo
perché l'idea coraggiosa che io vorrei
lasciare a chi è qualche modo proiettato
coltiva l'ambizione l'idea di comunicare
qui di mettersi in mezzo tra la realtà
dei fatti che accadono e e il pubblico
il pubblico che non ha il tempo di
leggere i caldoni il pubblico
che le svariate concessioni che ciascuno
di noi esercita e quel pubblico ha il
diritto di essere informato ha il
diritto di sapere come viene
amministrata La giustizia in questi in
questi 5 anni anni I mi sono accorto che
il modo migliore per rare la giustizia
che funziona di strati
appassionati In questa terra che è molto
complicata per ragioni che conosciamo
tutti sia chi c'è nato sia chi ci
vive ma anche nel resto del paese che
garantire una corretto esercizio del
biogo su come amministrata La giustizia
è una garanzia di una democrazia più
sbre però dovete sapere che il marketing
dell'innocenza è un marketing perdente
eh nessuno vuole stare a sentire la
storia innocente e non la vogliono stare
a sentire nemmeno I magistrati che sono
chiamati alcune volte a decidere
sull'errore giudiziario vi faccio un
esempio perché non voglio citare storie
di mi sono occupato direttamente
Giuseppe Gulotta è un signore che ha
spuntato 22 anni in carcere condannato
Aller gattolo per aver assassinato cui
Carabinieri si chiama la strage di
alcam
questo signore era innocente non era
stato lui a commettere elisto era stato
costretto a confessare c'era un
testimone che lo aveva indicato come
autore di queste violenze ha dovuto
chiedere la revisione tre volte l'ultima
delle quali a Reggio Calabria che poi ha
riconosciuto la sua innocenza
restituendola la libertà ce la siamo
cavata pagando circa 6 milioni di euro
ma lui ha fatto 22 an in carcere col
marchio di wia col marchio di assassino
e i pui ancora più recente il caso di un
signore che vi han ne ascoltati 15 per
l'errata interpretazione di
un'intercettazione
telefonica e dice Ma che ci stai dicendo
Quindi noi che cosa dobbiamo fare e voi
avete un dovere che è quello di essere
di essere attenti che è quello di
leggere
ma
dubitare dubitare
sempre anche davanti alla sentenza
definitiva
e secondo una stima
della del Centro Studi delle camere
penali dell'osservatorio sulla stampa
della dell'unione delle camere penali
italiane su
7397 articoli di giornale che trattano
vicende giudiziarie solo nel 3% di
questi viene data alla difesa viene dato
alla difesa allo stesso spazio di cui
Goe la I magistrati del Pubblico
Ministero e la polizia giudiziaria
97% contro 3% questo significa che c'è
uno smilano inaccettabile delle parti in
causa Questo significa che i diritti di
Giuseppe
culotta
da da indagato prima dao poi da
condannato ancora successivamente sono
stati completamente calpestati perché in
Italia non vogliamo sentirne parlare la
principale
il Il tema principale di alcune mail che
arrivano In redazione è Ma cosa Ve ne
occupate a f che in giornali hanno già
parlato e che i tribunali hanno già
parlato perché fa dei processi sui
giornali ed è un'obiezione sensata
quando viene rivolta ai giornalisti nel
momento in cui i fatti accadono Non fate
i processi in tv e sui
giornali ma ha senso questa critica
quando i giornalisti si occupano di una
vicenda dopo che unaria parlato e per
controllare se effettivamente il
risultato giudiziario corrisponde alla
realtà la risposta è no altrimenti
questo mestiere Non saremmo più in grado
di farlo e il coraggio delle idee è il
tema di di di questa di questa edizione
del TX di Vibo Valentia io concludo
dicendovi
che qualunque
sia l'idea che vi siete fatti su una
storia che ha a che fare con la
giustizia
accettate
sempre che tutte le parti in causa
abbiano avuto stesso spazio di
raccontare la propria versione
altrimenti il vostro ruolo di spettatori
e di cittadini attivi ad iniziano Diella
democrazia è stato gravemente menomato
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie